HARM'S WAY.
>> CAN YOU GUARANTEE --
>> AGAIN THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES NOT TAKING
QUESTIONS AFTER ADDRESSING THE
COUNTRY FIRST IN A BIZARRE TURN
OF EVENTS ABOUT BUILD BACK
BETTER, AND THEN VOTING RIGHTS
LEGISLATION, ACTING LIKE THE
AFGAN CRISIS IS JUST ONE OF MANY
OF YOUR TYPICAL THINGS THE WHITE
HOUSE DEALS WITH ON AN AVERAGE
WEEK FINALLY GETTING INTO THE G7
CONVERSATIONS HE HAD, SAID
EVERYTHING WAS GOING GREAT WITH
THIS EVACUATION AND THEN DID A
BIG NUMBER DUMP ABOUT HOW MANY
FLIGHTS HAVE GONE OUT AND HOW
THE ALLIES ARE WORKING CLOSELY
TOGETHER.
THAT JUST DOES NOT SQUARE WITH
PRETTY MUCH EVERY SINGLE BIT OF
REPORTING WHICH WE'VE SEEN AND
SAYS ISIS COULD BE RUNNING US
OUT OF THE AIRPORT AND THE
DEADLINE, 31ST, IS GOING TO
STICK AS LONG AS THE TALIBAN
LETS US DO THIS, THAT, AND THE
OTHER THING.
DANA, THIS WAS MEANINGLESS
ADDRESS TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HOW WOULD YOU FRAME IT?
>> WELL, ONE, I DREAMED A LITTLE
WHEN HE STARTED WITH BUILD BACK
BETTER.
I GET IT, THE DEMOCRATS PASSED
IN THE HOUSE WITH THEIR RAZOR
THIN MARGIN $3.5 TRILLION
SPENDING THAT WILL SADDLE YOU
FOR THE REST OF YOUR LIVES.
BUT OTHER THAN THAT, YOU CANNOT
TRY TO SAY YOUR DOMESTIC AGENDA
IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN THE
INTERNATIONAL CRISIS YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE HANDLING.
SO AGAIN EVERY TIME HE'S SPOKEN
THIS WEEK.
I HAVE A GREAT DEEM OF RESPECT
FOR THE OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENCY
AND THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF.
WHEN HE SPEAKS AND READING THE
TELL PROMPTER, ARE YOU INTERNAL
LYING THESE WORDS AND
UNDERSTANDING?
BECAUSE THE OTHER THING THAT'S
FRUSTRATING SINCE LAST FRIDAY
POINTED OUT AGAIN AND AGAIN, HE
SAYS THESE THINGS OR THE PRESS
SECRETARY HAS SAID THINGS THAT
THEN YOU ARE LOOKING AT THE
PEOPLE YOU'RE TALKING TO ON THE
GROUND, LIKE I AM HERE, HE'S NOT
ON THE GROUND BUT TRYING TO HELP
PEOPLE THERE, THEY'RE NOT
GETTING ANY HELP.
YOU ARE ACTUALLY HEARING THINGS
THAT ARE COMPLETELY THE OPPOSITE
OF WHAT THEY'RE SAYING.
AND WHEN HE TALKS ABOUT 707,000
HAVE BEEN TAKEN OUT, A LOT WAS
BY OUR ALLIES.
OUR ALLIES ARE FRUSTRATED THE
AND FOR BORIS JOHNSON TO CALL
FOR A G7 MEETING AND FOR HIM TO
SAY YEAH IT'S ALL GREAT.
I'LL ALSO SAY HE ALREADY HAS
TERMS FOR RECOGNIZING THE
TALIBAN'S LEGITIMACY.
YOU LISTEN TO WHEN HE SAID,
WE'RE NOT GOING TO TAKE THEIR
WORD BUT HERE ARE THESE THINGS
THEY NEED TO DO.
AND, YOU KNOW, I DON'T ALSO KNOW
ABOUT THIS ISIS THREAT.
THERE ARE REPORTS AND WE CAN ASK
JENNIFER GRIFFEN WHEN WE HAVE A
CHANCE.
TALKING ABOUT ISIS, AND I DON'T
WANT THEM ANYWHERE, BUT IS THAT
BASICALLY A WAY FOR US TO GET
OUT OF THE AIRPORT SOONER THAN
WE ACTUALLY NEED TO BEFORE WE
CAN GET ALL OF OUR PEOPLE OUT.
4,000 AMERICANS HAVE BEEN TAKEN
OUT.
AND THE PRESIDENT SAID WE'LL
TELL YOU TOMORROW HOW MANY THERE
ARE.
I DON'T THINK THEY NECESSARILY
KNOW AND I UNDERSTAND WHY THEY
MIGHT NOT KNOW.
BUT TO ME THAT WAS SUBPAR TO SAY
THE LEAST.
>> HE SEEMS VERY FOCUSED ON THE
DANGER OF STAYING A FEW DAYS
LONGER, BUT NOT FOCUSED ON THE
DANGER THAT AMERICANS FACE,
GREG, WHO ARE STRANDED BEHIND
ENEMY LINES.
AND HE JUST HASN'T MET THE
MOMENT.
>> HE'S, HE'S LIKE A FADING
TALENT THAT JUST HAD TO PLAY ALL
THE GREATEST HITS, RIGHT?
HE WENT UP ON STAGE JUST NOW,
STARTED WITH THE FREE STUFF,
LOOK AT ALL THESE FREE THINGS,
THEY HE DID THE CLIMATE CRISIS
OF COURSE.
THEN HE DID CORPORATE TAXES,
RIGHT?
WHAT DID HE SAY?
PAY YOUR FAIR SHARE AND THEN THE
VOTER SUPPRESSION.
ALL OF THESE THINGS ARE THERE,
KIND OF LIKE THE WAY THAT THEY
CAN SAY, LOOK, I'M STILL
PRESIDENT, THIS THING IS JUST
SOMETHING ELSE.
>> RIGHT.
>> BUT IT ALSO PLAYS OUT, MAKES
IT LOOK LIKE HE'S TRYING TO
AVOID THE OLE FAN IN THE ROOM.
WHEN I LOOK AT HIM, I DON'T
BLAME HIM.
I CAN'T -- IT'S UNFAIR TO JUST
WE HAD 20 YEARS.
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
HOW DID WE HAVE 20 YEARS OF
THIS?
BECAUSE WE NEED TO EXPLAIN THAT.
WE NEED TO INVESTIGATE THAT AS
WELL AS THIS.
BECAUSE THEY'RE ALL LINKED
TOGETHER IN THIS KIND OF THIS
WEIRD AMBIVALENCE TOWARD
AMERICANS IN GENERAL WHO PAID
FOR THIS WITH BLOOD AND
TREASURE, RIGHT?
WE HAD GRIFTERS AND BUREAUCRATS
WHO BASICALLY TOOK ADVANTAGE OF
OUR WEALTH AND OUR OWN KIND OF
DISTRACTION WITH MODERN NOVEL IS
THE TO LET THIS HAPPEN.
I ALSO WANT TO BRING UP WHAT
REALLY CHAPPED MY HIDE, AND I
HATE USING THAT KIND OF LANGUAGE
DANA.
BUT I'M GOING THROUGH THIS
COMPLEX PROCESS OF GETTING A
HANDGUN IN NEW YORK CITY.
I COULD HAVE JUST JOINED THE
TALIBAN.
BECAUSE IT IS EASIER TO GET GUNS
FROM AMERICA BEING IN THE
TALIBAN THAN BEING A CITIZEN OF
NEW YORK WHO'S COME UNDER THREAT
AND ALL I WANT TO DO IS GET A
PERMIT FOR A GUN AND I SAY THAT
WE JUST HAND OVER ROCKETS,
RIFLES, HANDGUNS, TO THE
TALIBAN, THE NEW-IMPROVED
TALIBAN, LIKE ISIS-K, SOUNDS
LEAK A SERIAL.
AND THEN POTENTIALLY, IF YOU
HAVE THE CA MANNED Os AFTER THE
DEADLINE TO RESCUE STRANDED
AMERICANS, YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO FEND OFF THE TALIBAN AS GREG
MENTIONEDED, THIS ARMED TO THE
TEETH WITH OUR GEAR.
IT MAKES IT THAT MUCH HARDER.
>> IT'S DISGUSTING AND THAT'S A
WORD I CAN SAY ON TELEVISION.
PEOPLE I'VE TALKED TO ARE
WORRIED ABOUT OUR TROOPS WHO ARE
AT THE AIRPORT, THAT THEY'RE
SITTING DUCKS NOW.
JUST A FEW THINGS.
JEN PSAKI SPOKE BEFORE BIDEN,
THAT WAY SHE DOESN'T HAVE TO DO
CLEANUP FOR ALL THE LIES AND THE
PHYSICAL SIS.
>> DIDN'T HAVE TO TAKE
QUESTIONS.
>> RIGHT.
BUT WHAT HAPPENED LAST FRIDAY,
REMEMBER, HE LIED HERE, THERE,
AND EVERYWHERE ABOUT OUR ALLIES,
OUR AL QAEDA'S GONE FROM
AFGHANISTAN AND AMERICANS CAN
GET TO THE AIRPORT.
SO AT LEAST THIS DELAYS THE
CLEANUP PROCESS UNTIL TOMORROW.
HE ACTUALLY LIED OUT OF THE GATE
ABOUT THE ECONOMY.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT HOW BAD THE
ECONOMY WAS WHEN HE TOOK OFFICE.
NO, IT WASN'T.
THE RECESSION ENDED IN APRIL OF
LAST YEAR.
HE CAN'T EVEN GET BASIC FACTS
CORRECT.
BUT HE HAS TOLD SO -- HE SEEMS
TO BE ALLERGIC TO THE TRUTH, TO
STRENGTH, TO COMPETENCE AND
REALITY.
AND I DON'T THINK WE'LL EVER GET
A NUMBER OF AMERICANS WHO ARE
STILL IN AFGHANISTAN, BECAUSE
THAT WAY, THEY CAN LIE AND SAY
THAT ALL AMERICANS ARE OUT, THIS
IS THE DATE, IT'S THE DATE
CERTAIN WE'RE PULLING OUR
TROOPS, YEAH, LET'S CELEBRATE.
AND IT'S A POLITICAL WIN FOR ME.
THAT'S THE DEPTH OF DISGUSTING
THAT THIS ADMINISTRATION IS AT
RIGHT NOW.
>> JESSICA, I WANT TO ASK YOU
ABOUT WHAT DANA SAID.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT EMOTIONALLY
CONNECTING WITH THE COUNTRY.
HE'S NOT EMOTIONALLY CONNECTED
TO THIS SITUATION IN
AFGHANISTAN.
HE GOES UP THERE AND HE READS
WORDS, POLL-TESTED PHRASES THAT
YOU KNOW HE DIDN'T WRITE
HIMSELF.
AND THEN HE SCRAMBLES AWAY
WITHOUT TAKING ANY QUESTIONS.
WE NEED TO HEAR THE PRESIDENT
OFF SCRIPT.
WE NEED TO SEE WHAT HIS HEART IS
FEELING AND YOU'RE NOT GETTING
THAT AT A TELL PROMPTER ADDRESS
LIKE THAT.
HE LOOKS COLD, HE LOOKS
HEARTLESS AND THEN HE RUNS AWAY.
>> WELL, I APPRECIATE THAT YOU
WERE LISTENING TO ME YESTERDAY,
SINCE I SAID WHAT I WANT TO SEE
MOST OF ALL IS THE EMPATHIZER IN
CHIEF, THE GUY WHO WANTS THIS
ELECTION AT THE TIME WHEN IT'S
VERY HARD TO BEAT A SITTING
PRESIDENT HISTORICALLY IN THE
DEPTHS OF A COVID MASSACRE
BECAUSE HE WAS CONNECTING WITH
PEOPLE AND HE WAS SAYING I
UNDERSTAND, I FEEL YOUR PAIN IN
ALL OF THESE DIFFERENT WAYS AND
SO I AGREE WITH YOU, I THINK
EMOTIONAL JOE BIDEN IS THE BEST
JOE BIDEN.
THIS IS, IF YOU'RE LOOKING BACK
ON HIS CAREER, THIS DECISION ON
FOREIGN POLICY IS NOT A
SURPRISE.
HE'S ON RECORD OVER THE COURSE
OF DECADES HAVING VERY SIMILAR
REACTIONS TO KIND OF THESE
FOREVER WAR SCENARIOS.
THERE WERE A COUPLE OF THINGS
THAT STOOD OUT TO ME THAT I WANT
MORE INFORMATION ON.
THIS TIMETABLE ADJUSTMENTS, THE
POTENTIAL FOR THAT, BECAUSE WE
HEARD AUGUST 31ST WAS A HARD
LINE BUT HE SAID IT'S OPEN TO
ADJUSTMENTS.
WHAT COULD THAT MEAN?
I MEAN HOW MANY DAYS IS THAT,
HOW MANY MORE TROOPS IS THAT?
WE'VE ALREADY START TO WITHDRAW.
SECOND THE UNIFIED FRONT WHICH
DANA SPOKE TO AT THE BEGINNING.
WE KNOW THAT ISN'T THE CASE,
BORIS JOHNSON IS NOT OUTSPOKEN
AND TONY BLARE NOT IN OFFICE
RIPPED HIM A NEW ONE AND UNCLE
MERKEL AS WELL AND THIS IS
SOMETHING WE ALL GOT INTO
TOGETHER.
LIKE FOR BETTER OR WORSE, AND
THEY HAVE BEEN RESPONSIBLE FOR A
LOT OF THE EVACUATIONS.
I DO WANT TO ADDRESS, THOUGH,
THE REPUBLICANS WHO SPOKE THIS
MORNING LIKE CONGRESSMAN MCCALL
SAYING THIS IS ALL JOE BIDEN'S
FAULT AND WHAT GREG WAS TALKING
ABOUT.
THIS DID BEGIN AS DONALD TRUMP'S
PLAN.
AND IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
MAY 1ST VERSUS AUGUST 31ST.
AND I'M NOT HEAR TO SAY LIKE
ORANGE MAN BAD AND JOE BIDEN
GOOD, BUT THIS IS NOT ALL JOE
BIDEN.
THIS IS, YOU KNOW, FOUR
PRESIDENTS HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN
THIS AND HE DID ON THE FIRST DAY
WHEN HE STARTED TO PULL OUT SAY
I'M NOT GOING TO PUSH THIS ONTO
A FIFTH PRESIDENT AND THIS IS
IMPORTANT AND WE GOT 21 HUNDRED
PEOPLE OUT IN THE LAST SIX
HOURS, THE LARGEST AIR LIFT IN
U.S. HISTORY WHEN THAT'S DONE,
ALLIES ARE HELPING BUT THOSE
THINGS DO MATTER.
THERE ARE THINGS GOING RIGHT A
MISSED ALL THE CHAOS.
>> RIGHT.
I THINK BRAGGING ABOUT THE
AMAZING AIRLIFT IS T